has started duda must win situation does
he have chances white's king it's pretty
safe in the center right now but if you
want to get any action going on one of
the flanks you need to commit it and
okay dude that is not a move he would
have played happily that's a really
reluctant rook shift from duda he's
brought his rook across simply to
defender pawn quite likely you will be
able to attack later on so for example
you will get
oh me and my arrows you will get some
porn storms going and okay magnus
actually played the move that i
predicted he did trade the knights and
then after this happened he's pushed
forward and
yeah and it's going to be vulnerable
actually for the rest of his days to
push
forward with his pawn okay
well you'll move from earlier ivanka
yeah but but uh better timed to put it
that way yeah so black's rook now is
attacking the pawn next to it that white
central pawn you have to defend it yeah
yeah surely step forward with your pawn
but magnus is
okay the pawn does protect its uh fellow
and we've got the idea okay it was
actually to come forward with the queen
to the h4 square i mean maybe you can
try and run away with white okay david
this is on the board actually on the
board okay do you think he's uh seen
this counter-strike of moving the pawn
to e3 let's keep an eye on the players
as well because it feels like this i
mean the evaluation bar's just gone over
that pretty much confirms our suspicion
yep that and magnus is frowning as well
that this pawn push for black not moving
the rook that's attacked not running
away from this threat uh but instead
counter-attacking is strong for black
oh he doesn't find it magnus but still
this is okay this is strong as well okay
okay it looks so counterintuitive it
felt like that was a knockout blow he
does step back with his rook i quickly
realized that i emailed strategy and
smack talk oh no that's bad directly to
the other side oh my god oh that gravel
gravel gravel okay
we have some moves on the board the king
king slides that iran to the right
you don't like it i don't like it
because instinctively it feels like the
danger is brewing there the danger is
brewing that that look at all of
magnus's pieces they've slowly
gravitated towards the center towards
that right side and kaya he's let that e
pawn go elsa
magnus yeah magnus sacrificing a pawn
but look at this the black knight now
jumping into the position
hitting the white queen that black
knight
if it gets captured that's a really
beautiful motif if you take off the
black knight now with the white bishop
then the black queen recaptures and
actually attacks both rooks at the same
time that's so rare to see two rooks
attacked maybe we could show this it's
just too beautiful that is beautiful in
this position right now dude is in huge
trouble let's keep an eye on the players
as well because if he does eliminate
this really strong knight which he
couldn't do actually here if he does
take it off then look at this double
attack capture the pawn or push forward
with his pawn okay it's more natural to
push forward i think so f for forward
after all okay i was just looking at uh
yeah
lenia dominguez and our time we have
game three the bar has uh
woken up in that one dude shaking his
head he's just played
it was maybe a necessary move but it's
an ugly move look at this last white
pawn push and talk to that white light
square bishop that white light squared
bishop it's dead it's dead and buried
behind its own pawns
and now black's re-rooting his bishop
he's just saying okay you've got a bad
piece look how good mine is going to
become
okay so that's why doodah steps back
with his queen
out of the eye line of the light square
bishop uh meanwhile magnus has grabbed a
pawn i'm slightly surprised he went for
it that pawn was up for grabs any time
he wanted but he takes it now with the
black knight so that black knight is
supported by its bishop and by its queen
so it could not be taken there and duda
he's trying to seek solace in an end
game potentially trying to offer this
trade of queens and say okay i'm still
going to go for the white king later on
i would be tempted to take the queens
off the board and then retweet retreat
the knights and uh
say
okay
you are the one that needs to win not me
yeah he's followed your advice there
ivanka yeah black's knight going back so
blacks are pawn up and white is still
stuck with this terrible light squared
bishop
maybe there's chances to breathe life
into the position again okay so uh
magnus attacks white's rook
first of all so that rook does shift up
one square and now i expect magnus to
again move that light squared bishop
because as ivanka mentioned white's rook
on the side there it is threatening the
black f4 pawn
that pawn under fire resourcefulness
is the key here
again the bishop goes back where it came
from so magnus making a bit of a gesture
there he knows
the last couple of moves haven't been
great for him he's just stacking up his
rooks defending his extra pawn now
but dude is maneuvering well dude is
going to retreat the dark square bishop
at some point then maybe aim to put both
of the white rooks on the fourth rank
connect them and uh kind of aim against
black's
f4 pawn that intrude into his half and
to the e3 square and then start
targeting some
pawns
yeah so now the black knight does step
back dude is slightly shaking his head
again he knows it's desperate times that
black knight is probably going to
retreat back next to the black king and
then come out again and it's just going
to dance around tie breaks wow i just
took a peek over he's completely winning
as well
it's not even that difficult so artemis
should take the lead now with one game
to go okay meanwhile black's knight does
relocate itself backwards
and the knight comes out to a defender
pawn and attack the rook rook steps
backwards and
yeah black's knight can move again right
now that's king can move the rook can
also move anything can a king can move
yeah so white's bishop stepping back
he's just trying to keep black honest
now tying down black to that f4 pawn so
white's bishop dark square bishop and
white's rook
just attacking it but magnus over
defends everything i mean have we
reached some kind of deadlock like if
magnus magnus magnus i don't know why
i'm struggling with his name today um
if magnus just does nothing
okay he can but he can also just move
the black knight and then start pushing
his pawns forward black's pawns now his
extra pawns they're going to become a
huge factor
how do you stop black spawns rolling
forward especially i'm looking at the
pawn next to the black king the g pawn
throw that down the board then support
it then throw the other pawn down the
board harry the h pawn is going to start
marching okay
okay dude trying to play on the opposite
flank yeah exactly yeah
so his idea is actually to break through
on the left side pushes b pawn one
square forward takes an eternity though
that's the issue
that's the only hope for dude if he
wants to win this game yeah push pawn on
that left side
open things up
but actually maybe that just loses
material immediately if white does this
okay he's done it he has to take the
risk bishop takes porn and now the rook
just comes over and swings itself across
to the left side and now pawn takes pawn
really didn't have a chance
yeah okay and pawn takes porn
okay look at magnus he's pretty relaxed
right now he knows he's under control
he's really chill about it rogue takes
rook
takes rook a set of trades and now white
yeah this is the killer i think this
last move hitting that white rook if
that white rook leaves the fourth row
then the pawn actually drops so black's
knight is getting ready to take a pawn
and if you capture this last pawn push
so black's pushed two squares you can
take it on passant as if it just moved
one square so white's pawn on d5 can
just take that black pawn off the board
on the side and there we see on passant
the pawns disappear and a double attack
white's rook has to defend his bishop
but now magnus he can just attack that
rook if he wants to he can take that
bishop off the board
he does attack that rook he does it
okay he's just going to be a pawn up
he's not even trying to win magnus he
probably will win if he wants to um he's
a nice pawn up with a superior minor
piece the knight much better than
white's bishop
it's all in black's favor here
okay the white bishop moves if magnus
really wants to secure the draw he can
just take it but he probably doesn't
want to he probably wants to
no i mean it's not attractive to
move with the rook and threaten
checkmate okay so this is why dudeo's
king runs away king steps forward and
now he captures the bishop and uh this
is efficient and clinical stuff from
magnus yep he's now two pawns up magnus
after this trade and the black rook now
is heading back to defend its king
against lenia dominguez and that means
that nidoming is he has to win
the next game game four to take it to
tie breaks a draw or a win for our time
and he will be ready for semi-finals
white is actually threatening something
but it's only a draw white's rook is
threatening to go up and check the black
king and actually black's king can't
escape it's just gonna be check check
check check forever but okay now magnus
retreating with the black brook has
guarded this eighth rank so no more
checks
will he resign will magnus offer a draw
just because that's all he needs how
will this end
maybe duda should be sneaking off for
the draw
just for his stats across the tournament
yeah across the whole tour but he knows
this is the end of his
um end of his chances in the
quarter-finals yeah and darkness has
guarded everything okay i know uh
another form well see magnus is the
world champion but i do know that there
was a former world champion that was
obsessed with drinking milk requires
some workouts as well i think yeah yeah
and bobby was also famous for that of
course the workouts and
okay so magnus he's just giving up some
of his pawns but he's banking everything
on this one runner this g pawn more
pride as well
between these two they might be rivals
for years to come and uh magnus he's
really putting the boot in he's saying
okay i'm going to get the wins against
you to make up for the world cup exit
and those pawns are coming
yeah so okay maybe the white king can
step backwards the white king has to
step backwards to attack those pawns
and maybe maybe maybe we'll finish in a
draw david do you think so
no
[Laughter]
no no way
unfortunately those two pawns they're
protected they're guarded and
it's not easy to break through actually
dude has defended like a lion in this
game i must say i've written him off a
few times i've said no chance of holding
the draw but
it's still not over
i think black has a few ways of winning
here so firstly if there's a check to
the black king the black king can
actually continue its journey into the
position but if the root goes behind
then this is what i was going to say
once the white rook leaves the first
rank black has the freedom to activate
his rook and white king will never be
able to move now
simple plan is to bring the black rook
to the bottom row and then make a new
queen
oh wow nice okay he brings his king to
this line okay this is very nice i mean
you're right there's not going to be a
draw at all it'll come in useful all the
time and okay we won't see that yet
but we will in a moment okay we might
see it we're going to see it now
we're actually going to see resignation
from duda he knows that once the king's
side steps the black king will help his
extra pawn promote and magnus is through
to the semi-finals yeah it's all over
and after three games today as well
magnus carlsen with a dominant
performance is ready for the semi-finals